one of the most exciting developments in
email marketing is automation this
session will cover three aspects of
automation that will help you stay in
contact with your customers grow a
better business relationship and send
messages in a timely manner all by
creating automated messages businesses
that implement these concepts have seen
their revenue increased dramatically the
objective in this lesson is for you to
become familiar with the types of
automation how it can be utilized
effectively and how to use automation to
grow your business this lesson covers
the key concepts of autoresponders
welcomed series emails and lead
nurturing all of which enable a better
conversation with your customer
marketing automation is one of the
factors in increasing technology that
allows us to be much more effective in
developing email campaigns that we can
automate but also provide more personal
interaction to our customers the simple
premise of marketing automation is that
we are automating messages that we can
predict and know that they will be
happening with certainty and so we can
pre write and prepare marketing messages
for a very specific events and then
either time those or make them
contingent based on a specific action an
example of a marketing automation
campaign is a personalized offer based
on a different applicant for a magazine
the offer is for a free magazine and so
as someone fills that out with their
name and their address and specific
information that information then goes
to a third-party data management
provider they are able to gather
information about that and then based on
the data we can then coordinate a
personalized response based on their
information and all this happens within
milliseconds if we know that this person
is a good credit risk we can allow them
to sign up for the free magazine if we
think they're a bad credit risk then we
can change the message on the fly and
have them call a 1-800 number to prepay
for the offer that allows us to treat
people differently based on who they are
based on their scores based on the
propensity to buy and we can also test
different offers so if we know that
someone is most likely not to pay they
just want the free offer we can change
the message if we know that someone is
marginal well we can test an offer and
give them a discount if they pay upfront
one company enacted a transaction
campaign just like this and what it did
is it didn't change their revenue but
what it changed where their costs to
service
P
people that did not intend to pay they
just didn't give them the offer and so
their net profits increased dramatically
because they customized the message
using marketing automation to get the
right message to the right person hey
once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simple
learn Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here